[Music]
so
too
[Applause]
[Music]
good evening dear friends and welcome to
our show
60 years ago almost 60 years ago
the mankind's jiri's dream came true
uh yuri gagarin became the first
human to go to space on the vostok
spacecraft
and those
minutes he spent in space turn to the
entire history of the mankind
he became the hero for everyone for all
the times
and today we have today's generation
of cosmonauts
had some experience and she will share
it
now welcome to our show um how are you
feeling what's your mood
great it feels great fantastic we're so
happy to have you here
thank you i'm happy to be here too
we also have andre barisenka hero of
russia
cosmonaut who completed successfully his
career recently
he spent two missions in space
and spent a total almost a year in space
on the orbit
hello do you know how you're going to
celebrate this
cosmetics day
four times who went four times on space
walks
and he's spent over 300 days in space
in total he was also the first
scientific researcher in space
we're very happy to have you all here
welcome to our show and we're going to
talk about
space flights about preparations about
fears about the future and many many
other things
so we are also going to ask you a lot of
questions that we received from
and are still sending us uh from
our viewers so let's go as they say
so let's start with the following thing
as i was reading about your successes
i felt a huge inferiority complex so
thank you
very much for that and um
so please forgive me if i have some
questions so that
are not very um
not on the level of people with such a
great background as you are
as for me uh i come from a country
which does not have a great space
program as russia does
nice so this huge gap between us and the
knowledge
maybe it might show and i was talking
with my friends about this show that
we're going to have
one of my friends asked me are you going
to talk about the sun the planet sun
and i said yes you know sun is a planet
that's laughable of course
let's start with playing a game
i will tell you a word one word and you
will give me your association
one or two
well maybe something different
weightlessness
is
many people can say that earth
life solitude
something i wouldn't want to experience
the unknown
it's interesting and the last one aliens
we will meet them soon wow wow
interesting okay that was
you know icebreaker and let's do
something serious
we have a very serious question here
from one of our viewers
he's asking whether cosmonauts have
their own professional
um jokes and professional type of humor
something that you specifically
definitely every customer has a sense of
humor and these people
love jokes so i really love training
with
uh different members of our team because
they all
fun to train with they make jokes a lot
and i have another question to sergey
as a person fear
to go uh 10 000 feet up in the air
why would you want to go even higher
into the black void
that has no end for me it was a matter
of chance i
dreamt about being a scientist
researcher biologist and then
it happened that i started launching
monkeys
into space i worked with satellites then
i
just became a monkey in a way i was so
to go on you will be a researcher but
in the outer space men have never had
any regrets about this because
it's so much fun some interesting work
andre you took a long time to go to
space exploration and you are one of
those people
who made their childhood dream come true
is that true
well as foreign i can tell that but i
think
my childhood dream has become true
that's that's right
and what was the very first time when
you knew
that you want to be a cosmonaut i
watched the theme
what film it was a
new release back then it was back in
soviet union days it was uh
taming fire okay we'll get back to the
movies and films again
later so anna you participated
in the very first open selection process
to join the cosmonaut team
what made you try you just wanted to try
no well of course not when i
first found out about this open
selection process
it was um you know the first time i
realized that the
actually the opportunity is open so i
had to
review the eligibility requirements
and you knew the same moment that you
are the perfect fit
perfect fit oh no i wouldn't say so but
at least i
got a clear idea of what it would be
like
so i knew the requirements and i began
working towards meeting them
well can we say that you are
one of a kind uh so to say maybe black
ship well maybe i'd rather not say that
but you're the only woman on the team
well in 2016 yelena syrah left to the
team and that's why starting with 2016 i
am the only woman
on the space team do they hate women
there of course
not well women always participate in the
selection process and there are
women who almost make it almost to the
end
usually it's for the medical reasons
because you know the medical
criteria are very stringent
there were two great candidates women
who were almost on the team but they
just couldn't get
on the team because of the medical
requirements well
i want to ask you what is your role
model or someone you look up to
in this industry well i don't think i
had any role models but i guess one of
the examples
i was looked up to back with his
incredible
uh story of talking to the
solid southern station and in addition
to that he's a great person he's a very
modest person and you are yourselves
role models for many people aren't you
i think so well one question from a
viewer
what does it take to become a cosmonaut
with ross cosmos or any other
organization what should they do
i think you gotta talk to the indian
space agency
and they do have space agency i'm not
sure if it's the
right name for whatever they have
do you have to be a citizen of russia
if you fly with the indian space agency
you don't have to be russian national
but if you want to be consummated with
roscosmos you got to be russian national
and
you can't have another passport
okay so i'm probably not going to make
it to the team
and india is developing their space
program they are
waiting preparing for the manned flight
so
indians they have a lot of chance good
chance to join
the cosmonaut okay then maybe i
shouldn't give up and keep trying
thank you for this information okay so
if you want to become a cosmonaut and
you
get ahead of many other candidates and
finally you're in this star city
you are going to train
for the mission so ah now you are an
athlete uh you have been doing rafting
for a long
time and you are probably very fit
so i kind of assumed that probably you
had no problem with a physical
eligibility requirements is that true
well you are right
yes i i was okay uh since
i've been doing sports all my life i
actually performed so well i
scored even more points than the entry
level
but that was thanks to the fact that i
was doing sports
but that's actually not the most
important thing
when you have to go through the
selection process to join the team
also there's another thing if you think
that you're good at something
it's not reason to you know just
take it easy you have to prepare
yourself for every task
every step and i was trying to do my
best
at every uh task because
uh they're going to screen
you know you and you know you see
and they see every every um success or
failure
so what is a routine
for a cosmonaut your usual day
we have a schedule for every day so it
is made by a designated person and this
person is falling for you to
pass all the disciplines past all the
uh practices and the
greatest thing about that that this
schedule is very versatile someone going
to the classroom someone is going under
water
or are you jumping with a parachute or
you are starting something
that's what's interesting about this of
course the preparation is very hard it's
very tough but it's versatile it's very
interesting so
we are we we must know and to be able to
do everything
do you get any time any breaks any rest
sometimes we have days off only
sometimes
wow sounds tough okay uh speaking of uh
this
centrifuge gagarin said
uh reportedly that it feels horrible do
you agree
well i can't say that i agree i didn't
know
[Music]
what uh centrifuge garden was there so
maybe
they went through stuff that really made
them sick
but for me centrifuge was my favorite
machine
during all the medical tests it was the
most enjoyable experience
i like the centrifuge too especially
when the uh
load is on the shoulders and on the back
well
i never expected all of you to say you
like it so
what you don't like the good chair is
the stuff i hate the most
all right all right uh sergey on your
website
i took a look there so that you wouldn't
be able to say i didn't do my homework
well it says that you took 750
jumps parachute jobs is that true well
my
mother would ask you a question what
about your knees
my knees are fine fine what about your
back
our back is even better
even better okay another question
if at your very first jump if
someone would just push you over
and you know
second jump does the fear go away
as you keep going well there is no
more fear but still you are worth a
little bit and i have become an
instructor by that time i was
teaching the guys who were learning to
become a cosmonaut
so we took a lot of time to my first
flight so not to waste time i enjoyed my
jumps and i really liked it because if
we talk about my background as a
researcher as a biologist it's something
that is against your nature
but it really teaches you to control
your emotions your body
and you become more confident
in the way you handle the stress
so that's the proper way to get prepared
okay i heard that as you jump with the
pressure
they make you solve some mathematical
tasks
in your mind what's the purpose of that
well if you don't solve the math problem
you won't
open your person i'm joking of course
that is
tough that is tough i nearly heard a
heart attack now
it happened a lot of things happened and
we also have a second parachute
did it ever happen that the second
parachute didn't go up
always opens yes we used to have some
problems with the first pursuit but then
we were saved by the second one
and has four cards so their
aim is to check how does a person
think during stress
so there is a microphone and dictaphone
a recorder
and then uh psychologists they analyze
so what you do
they determine the level of your stress
probably high
and you need to monitor the altitude you
need to look to
your instructor and solve a map problem
and to
open your parachute so that's something
you face every time you
go into space i see the last question
about
the trainings some of the um tasks
you do is for survival you prepare
yourself
to survive you know if you land
somewhere
somewhere that's not planned like in the
mountains in the forest
how does that happen do they take you
out somewhere into the tiger forest
and tell you okay see you in moscow
three weeks later
well yes something like that well
definitely they say good luck every time
that's for sure
but first you get uh really well
prepared
well can you tell us could you tell us
about your experience
so you survived right yes i did well
that's
really great so um
we had um a crew with two
more cosmonauts it was in winter and it
was in the flats
flatlands in the step so our task was
after we completed our training and
preparation
and it was a simulation of
an unplanned landing so
what we had to do we had to build a
shelter
using our spacecraft what was left of it
so we had to build a shelter and wait
for the rescue
team to arrive and give them a signal so
that they could find us
what about firearms do you have a
firearm
in your little case you know in case
some
bear attacks you is that a myth or is
that really true
well some time ago it was true i
wouldn't really want to be a person to
fire it
and we were trained to fire a
three-barreled
handgun so there are no guns anymore
now we have satellite phones and gps
navigators so there is no need
to have a handgun so it's easy to find
us the locators
so maybe they will reintroduce it
sometimes because it was a
functional handgun against predators and
we could file a rocket and then we could
use
uh you as a shotgun to get something for
dinner yeah that always helps
getting food okay we have a question
from our viewer
we were talking about you know pursuing
one's dream
do you think that people with
disabilities
sometime in the future be able to join
the space
industry well maybe one day i don't
think it's going to happen in the near
future because
if we talk about disabilities well they
are disabilities and for example
if a person lands
somewhere where they didn't plan to the
crew will have to survive despite
all the satellite phones and gps
devices sometimes these devices
malfunction
and it might happen that the crew will
have to survive for
some days maybe even for more than two
days
that we are getting prepared for this
amount of days and if any of the crew
members will have
disabilities it could really endanger
the survival of the entire crew
so in very tough conditions for example
in the wintry forest where it's
uh 30 degrees below zero or even lower
than that then every crew member must
do something but anything can happen
you're right
yes i understand okay i
see i understand that the preparation
and training
for the space mission is really tough
really tough
physically psychologically and
you have to do lots of parachute jumps
but what about
you know i want to say to everyone else
who is a little bit lazier than our
cosmonauts you still have a chance
you can become an actor so you can
become
a cosmonaut on screen
nasa said that they are playing to
shoot a film in space
and for whatever reason they decided
that this film should be shot
by russia not america and both teams are
going to go to the iss
so the film will include all those
interesting things we're always
thinking about like uh bears on the
meeting the crew on the landing
for instance you know tom cruise could
go in space what about you
isn't it unfair a bit well i
think that everybody has to do their job
he does his job well i'll look at it and
i'll be happy to see it well
the most important thing is that
everyone does what they're good at
well i wanted to ask how it could
influence
on the um space team
for instance if you have a shooting crew
right there on the station with you you
have your own team who are working
but you also have a certain crew does it
increase any risks
obviously all of them will work by their
own schedule so they will
work in their own modules because there
are a lot of things and crannies at the
station where they might film whatever
they need so
i don't think it is going to be a
problem
and to make uh space travel more popular
this kind of promotion because no one is
saying that tom cruise is going to be a
professional austrian
who will help to survive to dock his
spaceships
although they do these stunts right so
nothing of the kind is
required of him so there will be a
professional to do this kind of
work so to make it more popular that's
not a bad thing
and uh now when there are private
companies working in the space
exploration so maybe it will help to
develop space terrorism
okay how much responsibility is involved
uh
you know in sending a human who is not a
cosmonaut into space
they go through a preparation program
but that's a kind of a smaller program
right
so of course with these trainings they
will not be trained as well as the
professional cosmonauts so
we will only need to provide for
themselves
to find some meals to find something to
drink to use the toilet
in a proper way and if something
emerging happens
just not to get in the way so
that's what they need to know from their
training
i think they can learn this in six
months
if they will train really hard really
seriously
if they will get really immersed into
something so
they can uh that's what we do it our
center i don't know what our american
can repossible do because it's something
unprecedented
in your opinion what would be the most
difficult thing for actors who would
want to go in space
well it will be difficult for them
because they will
encounter things they have never
experienced in their life before
you know for any person it's hard to
experience something entirely new
so you know any person who would go up
into space
that would be totally difficult and
unexpected whatever they're going to
encounter there
well but in general i think the most
important thing would be for them just
to be more focused and you know they
should do well i think
well maybe maybe they would
you know they would want to interact
more young people into the industry you
know
to make it look like more fun
so maybe we would need more people you
know so would we have more people
join the quest to become a cosmonaut
astronaut go to the moon and then to
mars
well let's try you know to fantasize a
bit
you know try to imagine the future
you have children right if you're one of
your children said
i'm going to mars father would you love
him
of course i would have let them fly if
you love something if you like something
you want to share this i'm in love with
space exploration with space travel and
i think
it's an amazing interesting part of my
life
and if any of my kids
and i'm not insisting of course being a
parent i want to show them
everything but if they would want
something i
it would make me happy andre which would
you rather
have them go to mars or moon
i'd choose mars via the moon
that's a great answer i know what about
you
you're the path of break you so to say
somehow you already went to a
celestial body so to say i'm referring
of course to the
series 17 the isolation isolation
exp experiment which was a simulation of
the
flight to the moon could you tell us
about what it was like i would go crazy
there what was your
experience well i didn't go crazy there
uh that was um an isolation experiment
that's right
it was as a close simulation of the
flight to the moon as it's
possible on earth
some things just could not be recreated
there
such as gravity but we had
a lot of scientific tests to do
and tasks we got up very early
and we would finish our work past the
midnight
we had six members on our crew and we
had three women
and three men so it was an equal
representation
team and what can i what else can i
say well you were responsible for which
part of the project
right you are every crew member had a
responsibility to take care of some
part of the project i was growing plants
i see well did they grow to
taste well yes we're growing small
tomatoes
and we managed to try
those tomatoes because you know there
was enough time for them to go ripe
yes they tasted well and we ran an
experiment of our
own we cut them off before and after
they went right
so we tried to cook them into different
ways
and you know i was surprised
that uh you know those that we cut off
and they were just lying around and they
were
better they tasted better okay
okay can you you know ask and leave a
step out of the experiment
if you you know just can't anymore well
you know
theoretically you can but you get ready
for it
and you prepare yourself and you really
want to complete it and people go
through a
selection process and they are highly
motivated to stay to the end
and to perform well so i never saw
anyone around during that experiment who
would really want to ask
to leave wow fantastic okay
as you were growing your tomatoes did
you ever feel
like matt damon in the martian movie
no no it was much easier for me than for
matt damon but of course i
did recall that movie from time to time
okay
i suggest we now watch some of the
fragments
of the movies uh okay the
demon times
[Music]
okay andre did you watch this movie how
are you
how do you like it well i saw the film a
lot of things
things really jerked me and the modern
films that are being made nowadays about
the space
usually takes me 20 seconds of a trailer
to see it and to understand for myself
that i'm not going to watch it
wow okay another question how realistic
would be you know the idea to grow
potatoes on mars
well it is possible not like in the
movie but the way they described it in
the book
because the book in itself so it was
good that i first read the book and then
i watched the film and the book is
really good it has
no mistakes no errors about physics
about the
chemistry and the author of the book the
writers so
kudos to him for
the way he described for the responsible
approach
and in the movie it's obvious you can't
show everything and a lot of
things well the idea is different right
and i agree with country because uh i
feel like such a bore when we watch
movies because there are some things
that you
just know that that's not how it's done
it's wrong
but the audience watching it and they
like it so
if the filmmakers they reach their goal
they get people amazed and excited
let them do that i understand
maybe your wives have fun watching space
or sci-fi movies and films
they just turn it on and then they hear
how you criticize it what about you anna
do you uh enjoy it or you do you know
are you more critical of it probably
more critical
well i enjoy um a movie because you know
movie is always a fiction
it's not real we understand that but
i always like it as you know
some you know art
products so what technology was used
what effects were used
to create a certain uh reality
so i tried to um watch it as a fiction
and not
real so i enjoy it yes okay
let's take a look at the fragment from
the
salute 7 film
hello
foreign
well i understand uh you probably are
tired of hearing this question
do cosmonauts or astronauts ever drink
alcohol on the missions
officially alcohol beverages are
forbidden because
it influences the vital systems of the
station or you don't want to admit that
i
see or you maybe don't want to confess
but no one is watching you can
say just you know can you share in
secret
okay i understand you probably are not
going to spill
maybe you will tell me after the show
well um the iss
is larger than the station that was in
the movie that was an old soviet one
we have a question about the layout of
the station
you know from the films we're imagining
always
stationed in spaces construction
that is rotating and has artificial
gravity
but it's not like that in reality it
has a different layout resembling more a
tree trunk you know with branches
is it going to change what would be your
prognosis andrei
well it's not going to happen soon
because there are a lot of technical
difficulties and to use a station like
this it's going to be difficult and to
build something like that
in the orbit so it's not as easy as it
seems so spinning stations
i guess so we are decades away from
something like that
like i mean full scale like i says maybe
smaller stations
will happen it looks nice but
that's not something we need actually
because first of all the international
space station is the lab
the research lab and the spinning
station okay we can
create some gravity in there but in the
station it's the other way around the
idea of the space flight is not to have
gravity
to have zero gravity so maybe
when we will research everything we will
discover everything then we will build a
spinning station why not
so it's not going to be like in the
passenger movie with a
you know swimming pool and stuff well
passengers are different movie it's not
a research
space station it's more of a transport
vessel that is supposed to transport
cosmetics or passengers from one point
of the galaxy to another
well and this idea of creating
artificial
gravity with spinning well it can be
possible
and as for orbital station i agree with
sergi it doesn't make any sense to build
something like that and there are
projects
that have separate individual modules
that are going to be
floating near the station too
create the something that ruined a lot
of experiments
okay i didn't understand a lot of what
you said but
i probably understood something okay
well now we're
going to have a canadian astronaut chris
hilfield joining us uh he became the
first
canadian commander of the iss crew
and hello hello hello and he was the
first of the canadian astronauts to go
on a spacewalk and he's also a musician
he plays an acoustic guitar and he
played the acoustic guitar
in zero gravity so he's famous for that
chris
thank you very much for joining us
my pleasure it's nice to be speaking
with you yeah and and great
great to see you on as well
chris wait for you spent some time in
russia right you lived for about
two years here how's your russian
uh you do
no i can i can give it a try in in
russian for you
if you like but but it's very nice to
see sergey and andre and anna there yes
russian i think it's great it's not bad
as you're saying
okay we've been discussing uh
movies about space and there are a lot
of sci-fi elements
here you know whatever we think about
space it's about discoveries it's about
future it's about
something unknown well maybe in about
10 years time robots
will uh conquer the world this is what
people used to think but right now it's
and there are no robots taking over and
our real life is so far from those
fantasies
what's wrong with that why aren't we
there what do you think
i think life has never been easy and
it's because of robots
and it's not really complete artificial
intelligence
but uh you know just think about what
everybody
pretty much that's watching this program
has in their pocket
the amount of intelligence that's in
just a simple little phone or
or in your car or in the systems that
are around you
think about how we're communicating
right now i mean it's it's unbelievable
and yet we make it almost almost
trivially easy
so i i think we are living in the future
and
you know someone launched out of
baikonur this morning and they're
already on a space station where there's
international crew there are people down
in texas
building a an entirely reusable launch
rocket ship
uh i it's amazing the pace of invention
i think uh
i think patience is really important
well if you are surprised you know can
you imagine how much we are surprised
well people who do not go to space
well can you share well maybe if you can
your projection for future are we going
to see something from the sci-fi coming
true
to life um i think
the big change um saskia is
making launch cheaper and that's
happening
right now it's happening down in the
united states
it's happening in china there are two
private
uh launch companies in china and they're
building
new launch facilities in china and i
think that competition
is great and if we can make leaving
earth
cheaper like spacex or blue origin or
virgin galactic or all the other
companies
then some of those science fiction
dreams
can come true not just in earth orbit
where where the the four of us have
lived but uh the moon's only three days
away
and and within the last couple years
we've discovered not only
eternal solar power on the moon but
basically unlimited water
billions of liters of water frozen on
the moon and if you have
power and you have water then you just
need a good habitat
and you can live there and so i think in
the near future and you said 10 years
um i think we will have people not just
visiting the moon briefly
has happened you know 55 years ago but
um
but actually starting to stay on the
moon and
and to me that's that's a really
interesting next step
beyond gagarin 60 years ago space
station
mir and then international space station
um to now
going and staying on the moon that's the
near future for me
and and it's pretty fascinating and
complicated but i find it really
exciting
also
i couldn't agree more and there's a
question
we have from one of our viewers about
that
i want to ask andre uh what technology
or maybe what
material does mankind need to
you know have to go into space
farther and you know on
galactic intergalacticus flights
hopefully we're not talking about
intergalactical flight because we'll
need to come up with new laws of physics
to do something like that
but to travel across the solar system i
guess we need to
have a technology of protecting the crew
from all kinds of radiation that exists
in the outer space in the far space
and when we will resolve this problem
resolve this issue then we will be able
to
try to fly to the mars to explore the
mars to walk on the mars with our own
feet
okay okay i was thinking
just now this is so cool we're here in
moscow
and chris is in canada and we're
you know speaking in russian and in
english and i'm translating all this in
my head this is all
about you know international cooperation
it seems like
this is a space is the only place you
have
real international cooperation so i
would really like to talk about
your life on the iss because it's a
truly international project
sergey you were there two times
on two missions well uh my question is
is it scary to go for the first time
does it get easy a second
i went to baikonur in 2019
and i was there two kilometers away from
the launch pad but i was
so nervous i was sweating so much that i
cannot even
begin to imagine what you feel like
can you share what you feel when you are
right there
waiting for the launch
the feelings we feel pretty calm because
you feel it finally
i've been coming to this for a lot of
time i've been preparing and now
it has come the moment that i've been
waiting for so long
this waiting for a birthday cake
until the moment has finally come and
you get your kick your
rocket leaves the earth and then you
start
working uh doing this top that you've
been preparing for of course
we are worried we are anxious but you
are really eager to go there to start
this work
all right uh okay um we just heard
it's um you know you get nervous but
also you can
get sometimes eyes full of tears so we
have a
question from our viewer what do
cosmonauts
astronauts dream of when they sleep and
if they cry
where do the tears go
are you asking me
that's a question to you chris yes ah
okay
i i didn't know it was my turn um yeah
i was always curious if you watch the
movie uh
gravity which is a it's visually
beautiful but it's factually terrible
they have the actress sandra bullock cry
and her tears come squirting out of her
eyes
and and fly across the spaceship and i'm
thinking when i cry on earth
my tears don't come squirting out of my
eyes and fly across the room it's it's
ridiculous
no your uh your tears just form and stay
on your eyeball like uh like um i don't
know jelly or something where they they
just
stay there permanently so yeah i mean
it's very
emotional to to see the world that way
to do something that you've been
dreaming of to
to be separated from your family when
something important happens like a birth
or
a birthday or a death i i found my
emotions
were much closer to the surface during
all three of my space flights than my
normal life
and so yeah i think crying is natural
and
and it's really fun kind of to cry where
where your tears
don't fall i i think it's uh
it's i made a video about it in fact you
can you can find it on youtube
in space your tears don't fall know
all these stories from people who
already have been to the iss
uh they probably sharing them with you
on uh
so uh are you eager to go you've been
waiting long enough
are you nervous no i'm not nervous but
yes you're right
i've been waiting for a long time i'm
eager to go
and i'm not just sitting around waiting
i
keep training for my mission
um well i think i will be you know
a bit nervous not too much
but because you know there's going to be
a lot of work and i feel the
responsibility
and um you have to
you know just be focused in order to
do them all so i'm waiting yes so
are we okay a question to andre
so what is a routine a daily routine
is it the same routine for everyone on
the iss or it's different for everyone
well we don't have personal individual
alarm clock we have an alarm clock and
if it rings then
someone from the earth wants to contact
you to get in touch but we all have
alarm clock
like in the watch and these are
the watches that both me and sergey took
with my
ourselves to space and so does chris
alarm watches from the space missions
and yes we follow a certain schedule
certain daily routine so we plan
every day by the mission control center
and everything is planned from the
waking up at six o'clock nine o'clock is
that nine or eight
nine sounds good to me nine hours is
good
well it depends on what uh
time we're talking about so we are
living by the greenwich
times i have a question about time
how do you understand when is night when
his day
when is up where is down we have your
watch and choose
how much time it is because we can't
look at the sun
because we have 16 tons and sunrises
so and we can see what time it is if
it's a meal time or some other time we
just look at our watch to know that
i see i see so since we're talking about
watches and time we had
a very funny question i'm looking for it
right now
um a question to chris i have a question
to you from our viewer
uh you know when you're late for work
here on earth they would say
you know i was in a traffic jam but if
you're late for work
up on the station what you would say i
was just looking at the earth and i
drifted away in my mind
um when you're living on board the space
station
there's not just misunder control there
in corolla
just on the outskirts of moscow at soup
but there's also mission control
in houston and in montreal and in munich
and in tokyo and all of those mission
controls
are telling you what to do and they put
it on this computer screen
and this red line is moving across your
life
and it tells you what you're doing every
five minutes
for the whole six months that you're on
the space station
every five minutes you know whether
you're early or late
and so all of us would set the alarms on
our on our little watches uh
all day long to make sure that we never
got late um
but i think the standard excuse up there
is there's six people and only two
bathrooms so that's probably the best
excuse we have
what that sounds like my mom watching me
all the time
okay do you have someone on duty during
the night in case of emergency
automated systems that are on duty if
something emerging happens and then this
system will take first
steps what if you're just
so fast asleep that you wouldn't react
to that
siren is blurring it will wake you up no
matter what
okay do you get enough time to get
enough sleep you sleep well
chris a question to you what do you
dream of when you sleep do you get
dreams what are they about
i think i dream like most people but i i
i don't remember my dreams very much and
i'm much more interested in what happens
while i'm awake
and if you're on a spaceship uh
your living world is like a dream you're
weightless i mean you have a super power
you can fly you're you're an x-man and
and when you float to the big windows
you know all of russia goes by in in a
dozen minutes you go across canada
in 10 minutes the 16 sunrises a day
it is it is like you're living in a
dream so
i slept as little as i possibly could
because i was much more interested in
what was happening while i was awake
and you would love the opportunity
of being weightless and seeing the whole
world pour by
you you wouldn't want to just crawl away
and sleep it's too mesmerizing a part of
life
okay okay we have another question i
really like it a viewer is
asking do you ever fool around
when you're on the station you know just
following around making jones practical
drones
um i i i'm asking you to confess because
it your image won't be heard by that
tell me the truth please
do you do you ever fall around on the
station
well you you can dance in a very funny
way when it's zero gravity so we
are adult serious people but still we
are
jokes and so we are still creative
so and it helps to support the positive
vibe around the station
so i used to wear a bunkie in a
costume just don't ask me where did i
get that suit
that costume but i did that and that was
fun it was so much fun
we were all dressing up we had a
superman we had a spiderman
i was uh hairy ape so but it was fun
chris what about you um
yeah did you do any pranks while on the
iss
oh of course maybe i flew
i flew with um with roman romanenko
and uh on my third space flight and for
the other cosmonauts
they know rahman he is a super
professional
very good at operating spaceships but he
just
loves to laugh and to have fun and and
uh
to to tell a joke and and to make fun of
things and
and um sergey was talking about we have
a big bag of costumes up there
and every single time we had a uh a
conference
roman would dig through the bag of
costumes and put on some other you know
he'd come to the conferences
elvis or somebody every time because you
need it we're just
people you know and we're a long way
from home and you need
art and music and humor and laughter
just just like you do on earth
so yeah we're constantly playing pranks
and and having fun and
seeing who can go the fastest through
the station and yeah
it's just a bunch of people up there
really important work
and a very dangerous place but but
people having fun
i don't know i don't know it just sounds
like you're having fun
all the time while we here on earth
think that you are very serious
scientists
well i have a question to anna maybe
it's a silly question
but i was a bit shocked to read about it
that
you are allowed to make a phone call to
your family
but you are allowed to talk for a
maximum 20
minutes and only while you are flying
over russia
is that true or it's a myth why is there
something wrong with this signal
well we have problems with the
connection here on earth that's true
so we have a link through the satellite
so you can make a call to australia to
the united states you can call your
friends your family
fellow researchers you can talk about
experiments if something might go
wrong you call them and you consult with
them so you can do it through mission
control you can do it directly
we are a modern space station so
everything is now digital there
okay that's you know i had a
misunderstanding i just had the wrong
idea
so it's about every three hours there is
a break in the length
about five minutes or even less okay
chris just uh told us
about um well we just had a successful
launch from baikonur but has it ever
happened that
while you were on assist would
would it be you know like people coming
to this station bringing something that
you really wanted
you would ask them to do you ask them a
favor to bring you something
well sometimes we can ask
to bring something and the guys will for
a small amount of
if the earth if the mission control
allows it because there is a
restricted list of something that can be
brought
it is impossible to bring something
secretly to the station so if the
mission control agrees to something then
you can bring for example halva
or some apples
what about the crush what about the
bread crumbs you know what about
breadcrumbs in space
oh crumbs uh it's legend about crumbs of
course
it can cause some problems but you can
they are stocked by fielders really fast
you know brad is made in this size and
our american counterparts
if you heard that they call it barbie
bread or russian bread
so like bread for barbie and it was made
and purposefully
so that there were no crumbs bite-sized
bread
and if something crumb then you just
start a fan and then it all gets sucked
in there i see
what would be the very first thing you
do when you are up there on the station
you know maybe you've been thinking
about it maybe i'll go to the
window and take a look at the earth or
what would you do well
when i'm there uh i will do
according to this plan that we all have
the first thing i will contact earth i
will contact the
central flight control station that's
what everyone does
after that you get all the tasks
a list of tasks that you have to do and
you just
join the team and start working right
away
okay that sounds very responsible to me
very responsible okay chris
i have a question to you um you know
a complete flight around orbit
is around 90 minutes right so when you
go
around earth it takes you 16 times to go
around the earth during the
24 hours so you get to see
16 sunsets and sunrises
so do you get used to that does it
become a routine to you
or do you every time feel like it's it's
like magic
something something stunning
well i i realized that
i was only going to get to see so many
sunrises and sunsets
and the big difference i think skusk is
that they happen
fast you go from the beautiful darkness
and because we're above the atmosphere
the earth has this delicate pastel
purple glow just the tiniest ghost of
the atmosphere on the horizon
but you're racing around the world at
eight kilometers a second
and so you force the sunrise and you go
from the absolute darkness
to then suddenly the horizon seems to
start to catch fire
and then the sun starts to appear and
it's as if somebody
uh poured a rainbow on the edge of the
world and it just
gushes around the world and then bam up
comes the sun through the middle of it
and you feel uh through the window the
intense
instant heat of of the thermonuclear
explosions of our sun
and that happens in about 15 seconds and
it happens 16 times a day
so i i didn't want to miss any of them i
i
stole as many of those as i could and if
you get a chance to fly in space
i recommend you do the same thing don't
don't enjoy
or don't miss the magic of the place
that you're in
well i am a coward and i have phobias
i am scared of flights so it's
a slim chance that i'm going to space
any
time in the future but i'm fascinated by
how you are talking about it
i know that well
all of you have been to space to the
orbit
but what i want to ask is
what does it feel like to be
right there where you know endless deep
space begins
is it scary it is not scary
yes it feels dangerous it is
tiring work but it's amazingly
interesting
and you're looking your space home from
outside you can see the entire planet
it's an amazing feeling when you
a person wearing a space suit you're
just going out for a walk
for a stroll by the way how heavy is
this
space here about 100 kilograms but at
zero gravity you don't feel
wow that heavy
have you ever experienced
fear did you ever get scared that you
might not come back
i had a different fear so
i didn't have a space walk so it wasn't
part of my expedition but
i watched other cosmonauts to do space
walks and when your
friend a teammate is going there
knocking
on the skin of the sheep
you were really afraid that he's going
to break through this
fuselage so peculiar feeling but
obviously
that's how it's supposed to sound that's
how it's supposed to be but it was an
interesting feeling to witness it from
the inside of the station
okay okay well
no matter how much we can hear about
your experiences there we
still ordinary people have difficulty
imagining it because you know you're up
there
in space and you're hanging around sort
of to say in zero gravity
and i know that photographs that you
took
sergey they convey the feeling of how
great it is how unusually
beautiful if you
if our viewers have not seen them i
advise you to go and take a look at
sergey's photos
i think first 100 or 200 should be
i failed doing them so because i wanted
to share the emotions i felt
like chris i didn't want to miss
anything i didn't want to miss
every spare minute i tried to be near at
the window
because i felt like i needed to share it
and i started taking pictures
and they were a failure all of them
because still you need a certain skill
you
you need you know a trained eye to see
something to make it look nice to make
it look sharp and it's traveling
200 kilometers per hour at your station
and you
need to capture the beauty of what you
see
but then with time over time i learned
how to do this
i made hundreds of thousands of pictures
in my two expeditions and
it felt amazing and they look amazing
so i have enough pictures for
exhibitions i really want to share the
emotions i felt
up there they are amazing chris
i had when i was looking at these photos
i was thinking that we are so small
people
in this world in this galaxy and the
universe
you went on a space walk what did you
feel when you were
doing it or did you have some
feeling some emotion of how great and
amazingly huge the universe is did it
scare you perhaps
sasuke you keep asking if things scare
us
i think you're you confuse danger
and fear as if they're the same thing
and maybe it's why you're afraid of
flying
danger and fear are not the same thing
and and the greatest antidote for fear
is competence and so i i served as a as
an astronaut for 21 years
so that when i did do a space walk i i
knew what i was doing i was competent i
trained
in in star city i trained in houston all
over the place
getting ready for it so that when you're
outside
your predominant emotion is not fear
but it's readiness and joy and wonder
and i felt extremely small be
just in proportion because the world is
so gigantically beautiful
and huge it's like a a big uh
spherical kaleidoscope next to you but
you're separate
from it you know the earth the earth is
just a planet you're no longer
part of earth at that point and and i
remember feeling small but
but at the same time i felt huge
because i mean i'm a little kid from
canada
we didn't have an astronaut program but
somehow through all of that work and all
the international cooperation
i was there with my eyes seeing it
and when i looked the other way when i
looked away
from the beautiful world out into the
incredible
uh eternity of of the blackness of the
cosmos
it was it was just fascinating
you feel like you're on the doorstep to
everything else the doorstep to the
future
and uh as if you could almost reach out
and somehow get that
the the the eternal blackness of the
universe on you
i and and at one point we actually went
through the aurora
while i was outside the the aurora of
the world
pouring around the ship and pouring
around me while i was space walking
you know this little kid from canada
surfing
on the world's aurora it's it's a
fantastic human experience
and i really hope that uh anna and andre
both get a chance
to not just fly in space but to get to
do a spacewalk
it's so personal it's so uh
sensory yeah it's it's magnificent and
it's a wonderful
way to understand our world
wow it's giving me goosebumps and we've
just seen your
photos sergey and when you look at such
pictures
do you perhaps get a feeling that you
kind of you miss that moment because
it's already in the past
do you have a feeling that you'll miss
it well of course i get this feeling
that for sure i'm going to miss
all these things in my life because i
won't be able to see it with my own eyes
all these pictures so they are
captivating
they are amazing when i look at the
photos i remember the very same picture
but the one that i saw from the station
with my own eyes
and that's the whole difference because
no matter how beautiful the photo you
take
no matter how look at how beautiful it
looks on the computer
the human eye perceives it even more
colors
it sees even more colors than what a
photo camera can show
so and when you fly above a very
beautiful scenery
you take a picture then you see it at
the computer and still it's different
it's not how you see it with your own
eyes and honestly sometimes i didn't
want to waste my time to take a picture
because i tried to remember it to make a
mental picture of it
okay since we have chris with us here
uh maybe we could talk about cooperation
well i get to okay let's talk about this
say in star city how many people how
many years
how many people do you have on roscosmos
team
32 people all right
well some of these people will probably
never go to
this to the orbit well we can't say that
for sure maybe they will
well it's probable right yes okay
does that you know create an intention
um in the team between people
no i wouldn't say so i
well every person completes a program
and there's one program a single program
for the entire team every cosmonaut
goes for a list of tasks practical and
theoretical
and they strive to do their best
for every task on that program
and they just stay focused and
you know when each and everyone takes
responsibility for their preparation
it just produces great results that's
how we live chris i have a question
for you on the space station
do you have do you get together for
meals for instance for breakfasts
for example my grandfather was a nuclear
scientist and he spoke about such a
thing
in the academia there is sometimes envy
between researchers and you know you are
from different countries you have
different flags on your spacesuit
would can it ever happen that you would
you know come to a dinner join dinner
and say
i have a huge discovery i just made a
huge discovery and your colleagues would
say no no
don't tell them don't tell them they are
from the other team
and absolutely not um
well we don't just show up there as
strangers
i mean i i served 21 years as an
astronaut
um training and working all around the
world in japan and in
across the united states and in canada
and several countries in europe
in russia in kazakhstan um and
it's not like we're you know waiting for
a bus to leave
that entire time we're working together
and we're inventing
space flight and we're we're figuring
out how it's all going to work and
and obviously getting to know each other
and then as a specific
crew you you it becomes family you know
and you work so closely together
and so the the successes are shared
and yeah we would try and get together
to eat but
um at breakfast it's too fast because
you got to start the day
and at lunch everyone's just eating all
over the place but
supper time not every night because
people are busy and you don't want to
you know
waste people's time but as the commander
of the space station
i would try and get people together for
supper uh
you know as often as was convenient just
because it's a good chance to be social
and to talk about the things we're up to
and because everybody saw something
different every day
and um i think it's the same as you know
going out to our restaurant
and telling stories and talking about
the stuff that
nobody else knows so so yeah uh
it's important to socialize together but
it's not competitive it's it's a
international
space station 15 different countries and
it's different
than some of the historical enmities
that we kind of
cultivate here on earth you know we're
all there by choice
and we're all there for the same reason
and so it it and we're living under a
different set of laws
the international crew code of conduct
so so it's
it's an extremely tight-knit knit
tightly knit team
and uh and so no it's it's
joyful i don't know why the movies
always make space flight look so
sad you know apollo 11 movie or or uh
whatever that one was with brad pitt
everyone looks so sad
space flight is joyous and magnificent
like you can see in these videos that
you're running and uh and the reality of
it is
it's an immensely human and shared
experience
as we're starting to leave earth
right this sounds really friendly
the way you're talking about it i don't
want a sound there's a pessimistic
you know sometimes things just go wrong
right
there can be emergency situations i have
a question
there is a photo of rokozov
in the arctic
when he was forced to operate on himself
because he had appendicitis can it ever
happen
in space don't think that appendectomy
is
possible at the station so sergey has a
medical training so
i think he will tell me if i'm wrong
well what if what if you
you know the flight back would be too
risky can you do it right
there i think mission control will make
this decision during the first flight at
one and one
of our american counterparts he didn't
have an appendicitis but we
managed really well and there was really
life-threatening situations so it was
really great
but so how does it look like
because you know you have to use tools
and they fly around
we have a first aid kit for everything
so when we are trained there is a
designated person
medical officer in the crew that is
responsible for all kind of operations
if any first aid need to be applied
and then he does that because in zero
gravity everything is going to be
floating around
so you are attaching uh
everything the tools the patient and
then you step by step
start fixing things
when they announce that there will be a
film shot in
space well we think that you people who
go there
are heroes
about um you know a question that
viewers would never forgive me if i
didn't ask them from our
viewers of rt arabic a question to anna
do you believe in aliens do you believe
in
meeting extraterrestrial life while on
your mission
on the orbit what would you say to them
well well andre
would say and i join him let's he would
say see you soon
well speaking seriously you know
extraterrestrial
must be somewhere because life can be
really small
it will be you know
bit of a molecule and that's life
already
so i'm sure it exists maybe it's in the
solar system even
that would be a fantastic discovery if
we ever get to discover
that and the first thing i would say i
would say hello
okay question
i want to ask we just got it from a
viewer
a question to chris
well there are people who are you know
flat earthers who think that
earth is flat so what
do you think about about these people
well they're not really thinking um
they're
they're just saying something so that
you'll talk about them
and so if someone actually doesn't know
the answer
like a child a student
and they're curious and they and they
they actually don't know the answer yet
then i think it's really worth engaging
and trying to
share facts and share scientific
knowledge
and share an understanding of the world
and the universe around us
but if if a fully grown adult
is just saying out loud oh i'm a flat
earther because
they can be completely lazy and do no
mental effort
and people will pay attention to them
it's you know it's like a little spoiled
three-year-old child
so it's not worth engaging with someone
who's not going to even do a minimal
amount of work on their part
i would much rather engage with the vast
majority of everybody else on earth
who's actually you know using their
brain and thinking and curious about how
things actually work
and i think it's too tempting to to make
a bunch of noise for someone
who's just uh being intellectually lazy
but i i just don't bother i'd rather
talk to someone who's interesting
okay i think that's the final answer to
the question
okay since we all of ours are here
together
maybe you are sorry that you get such
childish questions here
but let's um address
some of the very popular myths uh about
space missions would you tell if it's
true or false
if you go out in space without a suit
will you burn with radiation or not
no you won't burn you know to death
well you'll get a burn for sure but not
fatal
okay andre if you stop exercising you'll
die in the end well if you don't
work out regularly after 18 days in
space you won't be able to return to
earth life you won't be able to go
through the overload you
experience when you're coming back wow
i'm impressed
so you have to exercise even there in
space
what about does space smell like
burning rubber
what's the temperature in space
it depends on what you measure we can
measure the temperature of the surface
and the surface of the station can be 70
under the sunlight and way below zero
when it's in the shadow
okay chris a question to you do you
always eat from tubes
does your food always come in tubes
no we almost never eat from tubes we eat
from all sorts of containers you don't
need a plate
because what you know everything would
float off your plate
you tend to eat out of the package but
the packages come in all different
shapes cans
and and packets and some of the food is
in tubes but
we really haven't had the majority of
our food in tubes since the 1960s
you know our dietitians and our chefs
they do a lot better job now
and i mean i wouldn't go to space for
the food but you know the food's fine we
all
all three of us who have spent time up
there we're all healthy uh the food the
food is okay
you know but but you have no stove
you have no microwave really no fridge
no freezer so it kind of limits the type
of food that you can have
but it's fine it's healthy it's good
enough
wow i am a foodie i must confess maybe
that's another reason why i won't go to
space
okay anna is it a myth that sun
is a huge star which is yellow and very
bright well yeah
it's true well what about
is it a silly question what color is it
white right
okay white uh last question to andre
can you see the great world of china
from space
i have never seen it without any devices
chris have you ever seen the great wall
of china from space from the orbit
even the very first chinese uh astronaut
who's yangiliwe
uh even he looked uh if you have
as i think it was andre said or maybe
circuit with a long enough lens of
course you can see it
but no it's the same color as the
surrounding dirt
and it's only two or three meters across
and it follows the contours of the
ground
so you cannot see the great wall of
china you can see the m-cut
the m-cod is beautiful but you can't see
the great wall of china
i see i see i understand all right so
we've addressed all the
most of the popular myths and
you know i really believed some of them
that's
how naive i have been thank you all very
much
for your participation well we
were going to you know give some gifts
to our viewers who sent some
funny or most interesting or cool
questions
well we've been asking you about traffic
jams about
tears in your eyes what which question
would you vote for
or a lot of questions about tears
traffic jam was fun wasn't it what do
you think
chris did you like any of the questions
oh i liked all the questions i like any
genuine question
um i think the question of what does a
spacewalk really feel like
i think that's it's such a rare human
experience
uh and it's it's fun to try and describe
so it's a favorite question for me
okay okay maybe i wasn't giving you
enough
time i was talking too much instead of
reading more questions to you but
thanks a lot we have to wrap it up
really it's really
sad to say goodbye but
before i do that i want to thank you
again
for joining us uh i apologize for all
the silly questions
but it was really great to hear your
answers and thank you for sharing your
knowledge and experience
thank you for being there because
you know i never even dreamt of talking
to oh
here you can see well some advertisement
you can buy chris's book
well thank you i really sincerely want
to say thank you for
being what you are cosmonauts i
was really nervous
you know but i am to talk to you but
it's so inspiring to have such people
who go
into space and inspire the entire planet
so thank you for doing that and i want
to address our viewers now
thank you very much for participating
for
following as our stream for your
patience
and um
[Music]
surprise for everyone it's a track a
music
track from underwood
music group it's a remake
of a good old song about yuri gagarin
and it's
about how he lived and a wish for
all of us to live
[Applause]
[Music]
yes
foreign
[Music]
me
oh
[Music]
um
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
ah
[Music]
uh
you